قررت من هذا الزلزال
ومؤسسه الاسكان التركيه
بتنسيق مع وزاره الاسكان
والبيئه
سيساهمان في اعاده اعمار هذه المدن في
اقصر وقتك وقت ممكن
بالطبع الاولويه لانقاذ الارواح وازاله
الانقاض وبعد ذلك
نعيد اعمار هذه المدن والشركات التي
ستساهم وتساعد في اعاده الاعمار ستقوم
برفع الانقاذ هنا
وافراغها وبعد ذلك سيتم عدد الاعمار فيها
في زلزال فان وفي زلزال بينجل وفي زلزال
ازمير وايضا
في الاونه الاخيره زلازل
كما تذكرون وايضا في فيضانات مدينتي
كاستمونو
حرائق الغابات في انطاليا ومولا
تتذكرون كيف سارعنا الى اعاده اعمار كل
هذه المدن بعد كل هذه ازاله والفيضانات
والحرائق الدوله التركيه في هذه المره
ايضا ستقف الى جانب ابنائها ومواطنيها
وتعيد اعمار العشر مدن المنكوبه
تعالى
سيعود
المتضررين من هذه الزلازل الى منازلهم
امنين مؤمنين وبشكل سليم بعد اعاده
الاعمار شكرا جزيلا